Good afternoon ladies and gentlemen,
I last communicated with you on Monday
to express our serious concerns
regarding the intention of AstraZeneca
to supply considerably fewer doses in the coming weeks than agreed and announced.
Since then we have been making all
efforts to resolve the situation.
We convened a third meeting of the Steering Board on Monday night which resulted again in
insufficient explanations from the company and
deep dissatisfaction among the Member States.
Now let me be crystal clear: the 27 EuropeanUnion Member States are united that AstraZeneca
needs to deliver on its commitments
in our agreement. We are in a pandemic.
We lose people every day. These are not numbers. They are not statistics. These are persons,
with families, with friends and colleagues that are all affected as well. Pharmaceutical companies,
vaccine developers, have moral, societal and contractual responsibilities, which they need to
uphold. The view that the company is not obliged to deliver because we signed a ‘best effort' agreement
is neither correct nor is it acceptable. We signed an Advance Purchase Agreement for a product which
at the time did not exist and which still todayis not yet authorised. And we signed it precisely
to ensure that the company builds a manufacturingcapacity to produce the vaccine early so
they can deliver a certain volume of dosesthe day that it is authorised. The logic of
these agreements was as valid then as it is now. We provide a de-risking investment up front, in
order to get a binding commitment from the companyto pre-produce, even before it gets authorisation.
Not being able to ensure manufacturing capacity
is against the letter and the spirit of our
agreement. We reject the logic of first come, first served. That may work at the neighbourhood
butchers, but not in contracts. And not in our Advance Purchase Agreements.
There's no priority clause in the Advance Purchase Agreement.
And also no there is also no hierarchy
of the four production plans named in
the Advance Purchase Agreement. Two are in thelocated in the EU and two are located in the UK.
Now We intend to defend the integrity of our investments and the taxpayers' money that has been
invested. We remain always open to engage with the company to resolve any outstanding issues in the
spirit of true collaboration and responsibility. That was always the spirit of our engagement
with vaccine manufacturers since last spring. Thisevening, at 18.30, the Steering Board will convene
again. I call on Astrazeneca to engage fully, torebuild trust, to provide complete information and
to live up to its contractual, societal and moralobligations. Thank you very much.